[Music]
Josh so great to be here with you today
thank you for having me of course so
let's start by telling me what does your
company do slate we sell high protein
chocolate milks and lattes ooh delicious
yes of course pace is number one
priority and we say we sell strength so
the high protein gives people strength
and we create products that are not only
better for people but better for the
planets we have an environmental Mission
too very cool I'll dive into
sustainability later but I first want to
hear about your founding story sure so
my co-founder Manny Luben and I are both
from the Greater Boston area and we grew
up playing a ton of sports after games
after practice our moms would always
give us chocolate milk and it was always
great protein good electrolytes I didn't
realize that chocolate milk actually has
more electrolytes than most sports
drinks just naturally so we drank it all
the time we got older became lactose
intolerant so we couldn't drink it
anymore and had to start drinking these
name brands that basically screamed to
the world that we were the guys with
tummy issues and so that was where kind
of slate was born we just wanted to
create a chocolate milk for us that we
could actually drink every day and feel
comfortable
with so what made you think then that
you could take this leap into
entrepreneurship and have a successful
business a lot of people talk about it
they're like oh it's amazing that you
guys were able to do this and I first of
all my family has been incredibly
supportive before this actually work for
a real estate tech company and I
remember when I was leaving to start the
world of chocolate milk my dad was like
how many people wealthy people do know
on real estate I was like a lot he's
like how many wealthy people do know on
milk I was like Dad that's the
opportunity that's not the so that was
kind of that big JP but for me I knew
that worst case scenario if I fell on my
face I my parents were there to to catch
me could move in with them I don't know
if they would like that or not but very
very lucky to have that support system
behind me I tell everybody to that going
into something alone is very very hard
Inception of the idea to actually
launching our first product was two full
years I don't know if if I was alone I
would able to kind of like push through
and do
[Music]
it now part part of the things I love
about your story is that you guys went
on Shark Tank we did tell me about how
that experience is for you besides the
55 page NDA that I can't say a lot of
the things that happened no it was
honestly an incredible experience as an
entrepreneur no matter what happens on
that stage it was one of the coolest
things I've ever done being out in LA
and doing it meeting everybody and for
us it was we did a Kickstarter video and
the casting team reached out to us and
so when we went out there on the show we
had no final product they were labade
samples we had no sales all we had was
the kickstarter and so we definitely
were a little bit early before wanting
to kind of be ready to go out there but
we were like you know what this is an
opportunity to get in front of people
potentially find a great partner for the
business and we got destroyed on
national television it was definitely
brutal on our egos as we say great for
the brand tough on the ego and uh it
aired about a year later and when we
look at it now they run it every two
months like it's on all the time which
again great recognition people still
tell us but and my mom is still pretty
upset he's like you got to let them know
how good you guys are doing now and I'm
like well maybe if they read forbs
they'll find out there you go exactly
you talked about sustainability earlier
so I want to Circle back on that how is
that such a big part of your brand it's
really important to us I mean I think
for us it's not only important to us to
have making humans better but we got to
take care of the planet that we're on
and so we wanted to figure out a truly
authentic way I think sometimes
companies get a little bit too involved
in the world of they need to do
something because they think they have
to or have some sort of ESG goal they
need to hit and so for us they starting
with the aluminum can so we're 100%
recyclable aluminum can where a lot of
things in plastic bottles we learned a
lot about how a lot of the waste that
doesn't end up getting recycled in North
America ends up in the Indian Ocean so
we actually partnered with a group to be
a plastic neutral certified business and
have plastic neutral certified products
and on the other side of that throughout
our entire supply chain find ways to
continue to make things better so we do
come from dairy we are from cows so we
have cows that we're using the milk that
again we make lactose free but we have
methane machines on the farms to help
convert that into energy to power the
farm so it's not just wasted methane or
hurting the environment so anywhere that
we can kind of bring that in we want
to and one last question for you Jos
what would you like your legacy to
be personally I've always been really
into health and fitness and somebody
like my dad and my my parents actually
both you know we've all tried to be as
healthy as we can and my dad has a nasty
Sweet Tooth he loves his chocolate chip
cookies and anything sweet and so for me
being able to now give him a product
that tastes really good to him that's
sweet but also is not sacrificing his
nutrition if we can keep coming out with
more and more products like that for
even just him help him live a little bit
longer be a little bit happier and
healthier if we can do that for more
people that's really the goal so just
leave a little bit of an impact as best
we
[Music]
can